larry the desperation of your opposition
must be encouraging to you because they
only really start throwing the kitchen
sink at people when there's a real
possibility the person might win the
anger is that i could possibly win with
as little as 20 or so of the total
amount of votes but they didn't seem to
care about about democracy when they
impeach donald trump twice with
virtually zero republican support but
all of a sudden uh it's not fair for a
minority of people to have their way
there's no question that democrats
outnumber republicans in california the
problem is republicans are super
motivated to go to the polls and get rid
of gavin newsom and democrats are kind
of like eh i'm gavin newsom when you
look at the polls one of the things
that's truly shocking is latino voters
are really
on gavin newsom they really don't care
about his fate which means that gavin
newsom is in serious trouble now it
would be preferable to get to a time in
california where a republican could win
a gubernatorial election just outright
without having to go through the recall
process but it seems as though because
california is such a one-party state and
the entire legislature is dominated by
democrats because of all of that the
only way that repo that conservatives
ever get a shot is if people are sort of
blindingly awakened to
what is happening in their state and
that usually happens around one
particular incident in this case it was
probably gavin newsom over at the french
laundry demonstrating full scale that
there is one rule for the elites and one
rule for everybody else but it seems as
though the bad administration of the
state for the last 15 20 years has
really come
has really collapsed in on on gavin
newsom and larry elder could be the
beneficiary remember there are two
questions on the ballot one do you
recall gavin newsom two who should
replace him
larry
is uh the person who is best slated to
replace him on question two joining us
on the line right now is larry elder the
gubernatorial candidate on the right
side of the aisle in california with the
best shot of replacing gavin newsom but
first as you know i value a good night's
sleep i need it frankly i'm a very busy
person a lot going on my kids wake me up
all the time i need a great pillow to
give me a great night's sleep and this
is why i love my pillow well my pillow
does more than merely pillows my pillow
didn't stop by creating the best pillow
they created the new giza dream bed
sheets they look and feel great that
means an even better night's sleep for
me which is crucial for a busy schedule
my pillow found the world's best cotton
it is called giza cotton it is ultra
soft and breathable it's extremely
durable my pillow sheets come with a 60
day money back guarantee a 10 year
warranty that's a long warranty right
there the first night you sleep on the
giza sheets you'll never want to sleep
on anything else the giza dream sheets
they come in a variety of sizes and
colors as well they have lots of my
pillow product at our house we love
everything that they produce my pillow's
latest incredible deal is the sale of
the year for a limited time you'll
receive 50 off the giza dream sheets
you'll receive a set for as low as 49.99
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square use promo code dailywire
there you will find not only this
incredible offer but also deep discounts
on all my pillow products including the
my pillow mattress topper my pillow
towel sets and so much more call
1-800-651-1148 use promo code dailywire
go to mypillow.com make sure you use
that promo code dailywire
we are joined on the line by the leading
candidate to replace governor gavin
newsom in california larry elder of
course my longtime
buddy my radio mentor first radio show
on which i ever appeared was larry's in
on kabc in los angeles many years ago i
still have a picture of that on the wall
actually he joins us on the line right
now his flagship daily radio program the
larry elder show is heard every weekday
in all 50 states on more than 300
stations larry great to talk to you
youtube van thank you for having me so
why don't we begin with the state of the
race so the polls tend to show this
thing is pretty narrow for gavin newsom
you're you're sort of running a weird
race in the sense that you're running
against gavin newsom but not really
because he has to be recalled in order
for you to even your position on the
ballot to even matter so what are the
polls telling you right now
well right now the polls are saying that
on the recall side it's about 50 50.
half the half of the people want him
gone half the people want him there but
the recall side has picked up momentum
in the last couple of weeks so i think
it's an excellent chance he's going to
be recalled and as you point out after
he's recalled whoever gets the greatest
number of votes to replace him becomes
the next governor and i'm far far ahead
of my rivals on that end
uh there's a certain hilarity to a
republican uh libertarian like you larry
uh being elected uh through the the
recall process and i i just i can't
imagine the in the immense joy that i
will experience uh at seeing you take
the oath of office uh at the at the uh
at the capitol will be just just
wonderful let's talk about gavin newsom
and why he fell apart here so a few
years ago gavin newsom was the bright
shining light of the democratic party
there are their feelings just like ray
davis back in 2000 there were feelings
that that gavin newsom was going to be
the future of the democratic party he
was eventually going to run for
president and then things kind of
collapsed in on him like a house of
cards i remember signing the recall
petition before i ended up leaving the
state back in 2020
and at the time there was sort of a
nascent movement and walt really kicked
it into high gear
i think it was a time he was at the
french laundry restaurant
he was sitting up there with the
lobbyists who drafted the mandates that
they were not following by not wearing
masks by not engaging in social
distancing
it was a hypocrisy he had his own kids
enjoying in-person private education
he mandated that you wear mask outdoors
he had his own kids at summer camp they
were not wearing mask outdoors he
exempted his own winery from the from
the lockdowns and about a third of all
small businesses are gone forever
and people were just angry at the
hypocrisy you know about the status of
our of our government schools here in
california 75 of black boys before the
pandemic could not read at state levels
of efficiency almost half of third
graders could not
and they were denied a whole year of
in-person education and that was the
anger uh people already knew that they
were falling behind falling even further
behind but he was sitting up there
incurring a twelve thousand dollar wine
tab and again having his own kids
enjoying in-person private education so
it was the it was a hypocrisy that
really really got people angry well one
of the things that's been fascinating
larry is that that was almost just the
the foot in the door for the amount of
anger at gavin newsom because after that
it seems as though he's been spending
every day almost highlighting his own
failures right he's spending days
with photo with photographers like down
cleaning up trash at homeless
encampments i mean that's been a major
issue in california for at least a
decade and he's spending time doing
things like like talking about crime
there have been major issues in
california for longer than he's actually
been governor but it seems like none of
that came home to roost until the recall
effort really got got ahead of steam
well that's right just the other day uh
in oakland barbara boxer the former
senator got mugged her cell phone was
taken
i'm not laughing but the days earlier
the oakland police chief held a press
conference and talked about all the
money being diverted from his police
department because of this defund the
police movement and a few months before
that gavin newsom was attacked by a
mentally ill homeless person
so crime is up something like 40 50
percent uh in oakland uh in in san
francisco in los angeles and violent
crime talking about shootings and
homicides and then you have the
outrageous rise in homelessness
the fact that for the very first time
the average price of a home in
california been has hit eight hundred
thousand dollars that's 150 above the
national average rolling brown house
because of the failure to invest
properly in our energy grid uh and the
severity of these fires because he's
done poor forest management and believe
it or not we're running out of water in
this state
so you add it all up and people have
just absolutely totally had it and larry
one of the things that's so amazing is
having been
literally a lifelong resident of
california until i abandoned the state
uh the the reality is that all of these
problems as you say were a long time in
coming i mean i remember when there were
water crises 10 15 years ago and there's
a lot of talk about governor jerry brown
why he needed to build more reservoirs
how we needed to stop worrying so much
about the delta smelt and make sure that
we were getting enough water to the
places it needed to go to how the
central valley had been completely
starved of water by successive
democratic administrations the same
thing was being said about california
wildfires which were an issue a long
time ago have these things just gotten
worse or people just started to notice
them
i think a little bit both they've gotten
worse and people have started to notice
them and it all kind of happen all at
once
and this governor has mismanaged the
state in ways that
are profound we have something called
the education of the the employment
development department 30 billion
dollars stolen money that should have
been given to people that were
unemployed because of the lockdown
mandates uh and the money was given to
prisoners who applied for unemployment
benefits and and to uh uh foreign
criminals like people in nigeria were
applying to unemployment benefits and
they got them before the one million
people
in california were sitting around
waiting for their unemployment benefits
then he did a deal for half a billion
dollars to buy defective face masks from
from from china uh
through a company that was formed just
three or four days earlier
by a bunch of his lobbyist friends uh
and it turns out he paid way more money
for these defective face masks than did
say the uh la mayor eric garcetti who
bought a bunch of face masks uh at
pennies on the dollar so you add up the
incompetence uh the arrogance uh the the
rising crime
rising homelessness outrageous rising
the cost of living uh and the the forest
mismanagement uh the rolling brownouts
uh the water
shortages it's all come to roost under
this guy's management so larry let's
talk for a second about what happens if
you become governor so if you become
governor you've now faced a solid blue
wall in the state legislature the
assembly is dominated by democrats uh
two-thirds i believe they have a
two-thirds majority in the in the state
assembly which means they can basically
do whatever they want they have a
veto-proof majority uh so what exactly
do you have the power to do what exactly
can you stop or are you stepping into a
situation that's almost no win it's just
you know you do what you can
well i don't believe that otherwise i
wouldn't be running and i spoke with
former governor pete wilson about this
very same thing
and this may surprise you then uh but
there have been lots of bills that have
been vetoed under arnold schwarzenegger
even under jerry brown and a not a
single veto bill has been overwritten in
california in 40 years
turns out once you veto something you
explain to californians why why the bill
was a job killer why it was stupid uh
and lo and behold the the lawmakers
don't have the gumption to override the
veto
i also have the ability to declare a
statewide emergency which i intend to do
regarding water regarding housing i have
the ability to have a line veto and as
you know the commissioners in california
are very very powerful
commissioners like the coastal
commission like the public utilities
commission i'm going to appoint people
that are far more sensible i have the
power to declare a legislative special
session so if you deal with just one
issue at a time and of course i have the
billy pulpit so you add all those things
up you can really reverse some bad
things here in california we'll get some
more of larry elter in just one second
first let us talk about a simple fact if
you're a responsible person you need
life insurance you never know what's
going to happen next in life you could
be walking down the street and suddenly
a hippopotamus launched from a catapult
just lands directly on you and as you
lie there bleeding out you think to
yourself man should have had life
insurance well if you wish to avoid this
gruesome fate not to death but they're
not having life insurance you can head
on over to policy genius right now
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes with policy genius
you could say 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
unions to compare policies the licensed
experts at policy genius do work for you
not the insurance companies you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying a
process eligible applicants can get
covered in as little as a week thanks to
an award-winning policy option that
swaps that standard medical exam
requirement for a simple phone call that
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes that's higher than
options from latter ethos and bestow
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you need compare
personalized quotes and find your best
price head on over to policygenius.com
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice and
important to get it right so why don't
we go down sort of your agenda as
governor you know there are a lot of
issues that you just mentioned and we
haven't even touched the fact that
california is probably a trillion
dollars in debt given all of its
unfunded liabilities uh and has the
world's highest tax i mean certainly the
country's highest tax rates uh so
what do you handle first i mean you're
looking at just a a rather large pile of
problems here
well one of the first things i'm going
to do is to the extent that there are
mandates for state workers for example
to be tested once a week and to wear
face mask at work which gavin newsom
just handed down i'm going to repeal
that before i had my first cup of
coffee also as i said i'm going to
declare a statewide emergency on water a
statewide emergency on housing because
part of the homeless problem is because
we don't have enough low-cost housing
apartments for people once they're
treated once they get up off the streets
and i'm going to absolutely uh do
something about the schools
it's going to be a ballot initiative in
november to set up esa's education
savings accounts so the fifteen thousand
dollars per student per year that we're
spending will go into an account that
the parent can control the parent can
put the kid in a charter school a
private school a religious school or
even using money for homeschooling so
those are some of the things i'm going
to be doing once i get up there
so larry let's talk about the full
frontal assault that you've now had to
endure from the media it is pretty
astonishing uh how fast you uh became a
white supremacist as soon as you uh
declared that you were going to run for
office so number one congratulations on
finally receiving your white privilege
diploma in the mail uh i'm eager to
welcome you to the white people club as
a jew uh you're now welcome in the
minorities who are now considered white
even though they're not actually white
club so i want to get your thoughts on
being one of the only black white
supremacists in america according to a
columnist for their lifetimes
well i worked very hard for that title
ben thank you actually i've been called
the black face of white supremacy i've
also been accused of hating women
because i wrote an article 21 years ago
where i cited a study from the annenberg
school of journalism which is connected
with university of pennsylvania
they asked women and men 25 questions
about politics men knew more than women
did in 15 they knew the same in nine
and women knew more than one uh and i
was just citing that study
and therefore i hate women the headline
of the article was the she issues
and she stands for social security
health care and education turned out
women knew more cared more about that
men cared more about the economy about
taxes and about foreign policy and i
quoted a female professor who's still
there and she said the reason women knew
less than men did on these topics is
because they get their primary source of
news from local news and she said i
didn't quote
watching local news makes you dumber
close quote
so i i was i was attributed to that
comment when i as i said i didn't say it
she did and so therefore larry older
hates women larry elder is the black
face of white supremacy who hates women
and and then of course you've seen these
articles from the la times uh trying to
basically gin up the notion that you've
committed some sort of grave illegality
and of course the headline goes out is
about a campaign fundraising issue i
believe but it was it was a it was an
issue that crops up in almost literally
every single campaign and is quickly
fixed it didn't matter the la times ran
with it it immediately started trending
on twitter because that's what twitter
does
right something called form 700 which i
never heard of and you have to fill that
out in order to run for office uh and it
turns out that i did not fully declare
that i owned 100
of my corporation called lawrence a
elder and associates
so we quickly fixed it it was minor but
for two or three days it was elder is
evading uh fully disclosing his
financials which is completely nonsense
and then larry there is also this uh
this attempt to go after you for your
personal life uh and your dating life
and i wonder if you want to respond to
that a little bit
well just nothing in there is true i've
never waved the gun loaded or unloaded
at anybody uh and uh beyond the rest of
it it's just almost too silly to mention
also you forgot that i was also accused
of being a self-loathing black man
because of a joke i told in a comedy
club 27 years ago the butt of the joke
was f lee bailey and the premise was
that ethylene bailey was enjoying saying
the n word in open court if he's
cross-examining mark fuhrman a black
radio station left out the premise and
just had me saying a bunch of racial
epithets and therefore larry elder is
not only the black face of white
supremacy who hates women he also is a
self-loathing black man uh who uh is the
white face the black face of white
supremacy who hates women so larry the
desperation of your opposition must be
encouraging to you because they only
really start throwing the kitchen sink
at people when there's a real
possibility the person might win
well that's right and then of course
there's been the attack on the recall
process itself it's been called
unconstitutional even though it's been
in the california constitution for 110
years uh and the anger is that i could
possibly win with as little as 20 or so
of the total amount of votes but they
didn't seem to care about uh about
democracy when they impeach donald trump
twice with virtually zero republican
support but all of a sudden uh it's not
fair for a minority of people to have
their way
we'll get some more larry elder in just
one moment first if you're like most of
us you probably carry a balance on your
credit cards and here's the thing if you
do and you do that for a significant
period of time you will end up behind
the eight ball in just insane
extraordinary ways because the interest
rate on your credit card is probably
ridiculous well right now you could
lower your interest rate and save with a
credit card consolidation loan from
lightstream rates start at 5.93 april
with autopay and excellent credit the
rate is fixed it'll never go up over the
life of the loan you can get a loan from
5 000 bucks to 100 thousand bucks there
are absolutely no fees you can even get
your money as soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
that's exactly what they deliver so just
for my listeners apply right now get a
special interest rate discount save even
more the only way to get that discount
head on over to lightstream.com shapiro
that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject credit approval rates
range from 5.93 apr to 19.99 apr
included 0.50 auto pay discount lowest
rate requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply offers are subject to
change without notice visit
lightstream.com shapiro for more
information so larry what do you think
would be the implications for the
california republican party if newsom
were to be recalled because one of the
things that we saw is there were some
kind of republican hopes in the
aftermath of gray davis's recall and
schwarzenegger becoming governor and he
of course served a couple of terms as
governor there there was this sort of
feeling when that first happened that
maybe this was the come back for the
california republican party and then it
turns out that schwarzenegger presided
over what what was almost certainly
a massive downslide for the california
republican party governor is essentially
a centrist democrat uh as opposed to a
republican and which means the last real
republican governor that we've had was
in fact pete wilson and that's been two
decades what would it mean for the
republican party and do you think that
that that republican party could you
know spring back into some form of real
robust existence were you governor
i really do uh what happened with arnold
schwarzenegger is he came out of
hollywood then he was used to people
loving on him he was a terminator and
once he began making mild criticisms
about the teachers unions and mild
criticisms about the nurses union he
completely caved and he went to the left
i'm used to people calling me names i'm
using people calling me an uncle tom
i'm not going up there to make friends i
have no illusions i want to be in court
from day one but the other thing that'll
happen in my opinion is this because i'm
from the inner city because i went to
public schools because i can talk to
regular people in regular ways
i think i'm going to improve the brand
of the republican party i think people
are going to find out that i've got
common sense and many of these problems
that we're facing uh could be resolved
with common sense i think it'll improve
the republican brand but the other big
thing will happen is this a lot of
people feel that dianne feinstein
mentally is in worse shape than uh than
joe biden no one's seen her in weeks if
not months
and there's a good chance that once i
become governor uh she may no longer be
senator and as you know we have a 50 50
split uh in the senate and washington dc
so this would be a profound policy ship
and power shift if i report if i if i
appoint a republican successor which i
most certainly will do uh if and when
dianne feinstein vacates that position i
very much look forward to senator dennis
prager uh from the state of of
california uh if if you become governor
larry now
after the recall election uh you have
basically a year right because there's
another election in 2022 that is up so
that doesn't give you a whole hell of a
lot of time um
can gavin newsom i assume he can run for
election in 2022 if he gets recalled in
i assume he can but during that time
again you're going to find a common
sense guy a guy who understands
california a guy is going to be able to
tackle some of the problems and if
there's an appreciable improvement in
the lives of people i'm going to be
overwhelmingly elected for a full term
so i'm not worried about that
well larry elder is running for governor
to replace gavin newsom gavin newsom is
in some trouble here and we can only
hope and pray that we get past round one
in which he's recalled because larry
elder would then likely end up as
governor of california which would just
be hysterically funny and wonderful in
every possible way larry how can people
help out the campaign
they can go to elector.com elect
elder.com because my opponent can raise
and spend an unlimited amount of money
banned and he's already raised about 50
million dollars from the usual suspects
the teachers union the public sector
unions hollywood and big tech i'm gonna
be outspent uh probably ten to one but
so many people are angry uh and even if
they cheat and i'm worried about that i
still think we're gonna win so go to
elector.com elect elder.com throw a
little something in the tip jar let's
try and make this a fair fight well go
check it out right now and again i could
not be getting more enjoyment uh out of
this it's almost enough to make me want
to move back to california if they elect
larry elder governor i say almost
because florida is pretty great larry
thanks for the time
i think senator ben ben shapiro has a
nice ring to it too don't you
oh man
oh no
larry appreciate it
thanks man
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed